of the slurping
the velocity increases like the dyson
guy
yeah german not english um hey what do
you guys think hodge twins
yeah nothing like perpetuating the
original stereotype yeah the hodgkins
are not here this morning
so actually no it was a miscommunication
uh on our part with travel and stuff
like that so
um which led to their sleeping in um
on the show today because many of you
thought oh we're gonna be softening we
have alex jones so we're only going to
be here for a few minutes
and then go live to something that we
taped uh just a little bit earlier
with alex jones in the streets of austin
warning for parents who don't want to
hear well don't want their children to
hear the words
bum piss repeatedly yeah multiple times
because we encounter it though
it's contextual kind of like i realized
we were just listening to pogo before
the break
you know and sorry oh my headphones just
went out here this is a disaster
what is happening here okay so and i
real like it's context like you know
this is
you realize this is a dance you know
people do this yeah it's like oh you're
thrusting your
hips yeah well really that's mimicking
sexual movement
it's sexual undulation but there's this
is okay
yeah it's all well it's okay
which used to be a derogatory term for
italian yeah so um
but it's all this is okay but i realized
what's not okay it just changes the face
right so this this is fine
but this is
my point here is context over content
see you thought you weren't going to get
anything out of this show intellectual
this show
so my ques i have a couple of questions
you since we have alex jones on
uh today do you think that the the
banning of alex jones was right now i
will say this
we've gone in hard on alex jones quite a
few times sure where i just agree with
him a whole lot namely on the conspiracy
theories and i've done so on his show
right that's true i don't think he's a
guy who ever should have been banned and
i will say
personally we've always had a very he's
always been very respectful and had a
friendly relationship he's a good guy
it's fun it's fun like if you have like
kids who are really high energy
and they're fun for a little bit but
then you can if you're the babysitter
yeah
but not if you're like a little you know
like high energy bulldogs
alex jones and he alex jones is you know
he fluctuates in weight he's talked
about on the show
but he um even when he's been like when
he's really lean he used to swim
he was a he was a swimmer competitive
swimmer he still built like
uh the uh the the barrel that someone
would go over a waterfall in
yeah that makes sense like they would
just crawl in alex jones
and go over the waterfall like sassy and
homeward bound tough
so my question is do you think he should
have been banned and then if donald
trump
wins the election what do you think the
charges are going to be
election fraud russian interfering
golden showers with prostitutes at the
taj mahal wherever it is i
i don't know but we're going to talk
about this more with the hajj twins on
wednesday because the idea of mail-in
voting
and the idea of sort of bussing people
and the idea of lowering the barrier to
entry to vote
has often been uh ascribed to
disenchanted minorities right and
there's a historical context there where
you talk about
sort of litera literacy tests and you
look at them because obviously they
didn't really have the same kind of a
place in
the schooling system that it was
discriminatory at some point i don't
really think that's comparable
for example to a license
or a form of identification yeah or sh
or just
showing up at this point the goal posts
moved
the last few elections it was like hey
you should have to have a valid id yeah
and now it's just hey people should have
to uh
be yeah to vote
ontological reality and i say this as
someone i have
had to do absentee voting because i was
touring doing stand-up comedy yeah
now that's different because that's a
very long process where you have to
submit your address get submit your
voter id at least it was
where i was at that point you had to
submit some kind of valid identification
go through the process
and then it wasn't just all right send
in any mail and no there was there was a
multi-step process
what they're talking about right now
effectively with mail-in voting is just
you know you wanna you don't even have
to go now
here's the thing the left is pushing
very hard for we had a whole segment
ready but the hajj one slipped and so it
deserves more time
than we can give it this morning but i
do want to let you know uh before we
start talking about the postal service
and amazon and jeff bezos and you know
alex jones so probably the building
um there is there are a multitude of
reasons that mail-in voting
is a real problem and it's not political
and by the way it wasn't political until
this election there was pretty much
unilateral agreement you can argue about
what happened with
with gerrymandering you can argue about
some kind of well you can't argue about
it but the left did argue about voter
identification
however until this election and this is
obviously because of covet is what they
would claim
the idea of showing up at the polls and
it's your duty as an american citizen to
pull that lever punch
you know punch that ticket which in
florida they go i don't know what the
point is
you should show up and do it it's only
changed recently
and there are plenty of examples as to
where i mean in new jersey this happened
not too long ago by the way there's a
long history as to why it hasn't worked
but just recently let me rattle this off
1.4 million voters they participated 87
percent of them did it by
by mail uh 65 000 ballots had to be
thrown out for arriving late okay
michigan just had 846 ballots thrown out
because uh
voters were dead uh then you also have
yeah they definitely can't show up in
that instance right four
elections from heritage uh that were
stolen that we know of
school board election fresno county uh
mayoral election miami in 1997 a
democratic
primary in east chicago uh indiana so i
guess east chicago indiana that's right
it's kind of like
toledo is basically michigan and east st
louis is
actually illinois uh and a congressional
election in north carolina the ninth
district in 2018.
there are plenty of examples as to why
this can be a problem now if you think
that we need to somehow create a
foolproof system due to covid
before this election that's more of a
valid
argument to make you have somewhat of a
leg to stand up but that's not what the
left is saying right now the left is
saying
what was so funny to me is uh i tuned in
to cnn this morning
and i hate to say it but the uh well
that's funny the the armenian genocide
deniers
um yeah uh and they were complaining
saying you know when donald trump said
maybe we'll have to maybe we'll have to
host this election later what do you
think
can you believe that he wants to delay
the election yeah the election's
supposed to happen on the day
cnn this morning armenian genocide
dinars were saying well the thing is
we need to do mail-in ballots and it is
going to take four three to six days
by the way studies show a week to get
the results wow and results that aren't
right a three percent margin of error
keep in mind
that's all the swing states wow three
percent plus or minus three percent
oh hold on a second what about michigan
pennsylvania what's the well it's not
like 1.5 i mean
oh that seems consequential racist so
we'll talk about that more with the
hospital yeah and it's three percent of
a huge country
yeah right so that represents thousands
and thousands of people
right yeah it's not three percent of not
good when donald trump says it but
whenever new zealand does it
right it's all good yeah it's all good
to do i don't even know what's going on
with new zealand i don't follow them
since lord of the rings
trash but they do have good beef
from what i hear i can't afford it i'm
an online host they don't have the cnn
budgets
right turner's coming up in a wildebeest
offering me buckets of cash
so uh i want to hear from you what do
you think about mail-in voting
and do you think that alex jones do you
think it was
whether you agree first off actually you
know what let me let me do this list a
and b when you answer this question in
the comments now i'll be reading them
i've actually
been been trying to read some more of
them lately a
were you an alex jones fan do you
consider yourself someone who agrees
with alex jones
okay then b was alex jones uh was his
banning
right should he have been so did you
agree with him do you
did you support him and then do you
think it was a justified banning because
i think the results may surprise a lot
of people
yeah uh we're gonna go alex jones
tomorrow there's another change my mind
of course by the way hit the
notification bell
if you haven't yet because subscriptions
don't mean a whole lot we broadcast
every morning now through election at 10
a.m eastern that's good morning mug club
and thursday we have the full live
stream
of the democratic convention so uh
there's a whole lot of fun it's going to
be horrible
coming down the pike i've heard people
say coming down the pipe i guess both
can work this pike
because you're coming down like a people
coming down a pipe i don't really like
using the pipe now
because zebra mussels invasive species
china get your [ __ ] together
uh we will be back right after this with
alex jones uh after this installment of
uh paco the friendly homophobe
and now for a message from paco the
friendly homophobe
that's me
mr evanez mr yemenez paco
hi yeah can you make sure that you and
your guys get the bushes this time
because last time
you missed them and i really need to
trim the hedges see i trimmed the bushes
i'm sorry for the mistake last time
that's fine would you or your crew like
some
long island iced teas or pepperidge farm
cookies no it's okay
nothing i can get you no not for me and
even though it's
because you're a very nice man and when
i say this i mean no offense
because you pay me very well and treat
me
very much like a professional but i am
not comfortable
drinking from your glass or eating from
your cooking jar
because you are not straight
all right here we go alex jones on sixth
street
that was uh once the most happened place
here in austin
by the way what's the best best place
for people to find you is it so infowars
infowars.com and band on video and video
uh more important than ever because with
all these doctors they've been banning
off the internet
for having their speech uh all because
dr bill gates says they don't have any
speech now well they
do have speech still at band video all
these doctors there's hundreds of
doctors that have been silenced
banned video now you know we did a
segment down in deep ellum uh
one morning and i was surprised how
everything was boarded up i was very
surprised when we came down here in
sixth street for people if we can
see everything going on everything is
boarded up um
all the black lives matter and stuff
sprayed over it right right and if you
try and paint over that if a business
owner does they can actually be charged
with a hate crime in some cases it can
be actually criminal
to wash your own wall that's right now
that george soros
financed communist anti-american
propaganda
on your property on your boarded up
business is
a civil right and if you paint over it
you get charged the hate crime yeah well
there was a business owner who will
remain nameless in dallas who was like i
just cleaned that
and then he just ended up having to
leave it up you know one guy who we
interviewed yesterday when we were doing
the change of mind
said these boards were up for kovit so
can you tell me is it covader is it more
so the rioting and breaking the windows
it was both when covet started really
six months
ago here some of the big corporations
boarded up because they were on the
inside baseball that this was going to
be a
permanent shutdown until trump was
driven from office but the smaller
businesses tried to stay open but then
the city ordered them closed but they
didn't board up but then
right after that happened they activated
and when the george floyd incident
happened the black lives matter
and the anti-fun so they began smashing
out windows and that's when basically
everything got boarded up yeah i mean
almost everything is boarded up here and
what's funny is you look at a lot of
these places
a lot of these places are sort of
hipster bars in austin that would be
supportive
of this movement i hate to say it i kind
of think and i know it's your hometown
sort of deserves to eat itself alive
right now well it does i mean i love
austin what what used to be but now it
is the excrement of
los angeles and san francisco and
portland and seattle all those people
have fled here
and so austin is now the worst parts of
the west coast
cultural spiritual toilet right
and so this is not austin this is now
literally the sphincter
of the poison blue cities around the
country uh that are now emptying out
like rats leaving a sinking ship
so this is no longer awesome this is l.a
well here let's let's pause for a second
everyone
will not pause but stop moving look we
have been some of the only people around
obviously we have some other camera folk
security here
it's been nothing but on sixth street
boards and hobos
it's like austin is just the new city
motto could just be bum
piss well it used to be the live music
capital the world
right and now it is the capital of
bumpus and needles
and feces uh and all sorts of mentally
ill people and antifa and blm running
around
burning things down it's very very sad
look i love texas but i want texas to
know california used to be
red as it can get and now it is a blue
cesspit so there's this arrogance in
red states like vermont used to be red
and now it's deep deep blue
people better wake the hell up and push
back culturally or the left will take
your ass over like quicksand
as an example of how fast it can change
you ever see white christmas with pink
crosby
danny k um they say at one point they're
talking about getting all of the old uh
the old army gents together you know
the uh general's bed and breakfast yeah
he says you'd have a better chance at
finding a democrat in vermont than
pulling that off i love that old movie
exactly so right wing
yeah the people had no idea that vermont
used to be sort of the place where the
wealthy would go and ski
do you have any ideas to what the number
is in property damage here
um crimes i mean obviously everyone
knows about garrett foster that's what's
been going on well there are
conservative numbers but it's in the
hundreds of millions of dollars
and then it's in the billions just in
central texas
what the coveted lockdown has done but
but no one's really sure of the number
because
most people have not been able to get
the unemployment or get the bailout
check
yeah they spend weeks on those computers
and then by the time they get on it all
the money's gone
so almost everyone i know who are
including even middle class people
that got laid off or lost their jobs
they've never gotten any of this magical
stimulus money
right yeah so you're saying hundreds of
millions just in austin i know it's
the number that we found and it's very
hard to find these numbers and you
obviously have a lot more researchers
than i do
was 600 million dollars in damage
countrywide from the riots
but you're saying you think it's
hundreds of millions just in austin i'm
talking about what covett has done
with the destruction of the businesses
and some of the businesses that got
broken into and robbed so
i think you're right no one knows the
actual number but they're saying austin
with both things together has lost
billions yeah that makes sense it's
really hard
to find some of these numbers for
example uh you know my home state of
michigan
right they were going to release the
covid nursing home deaths what were i
think the number of one point they said
it was close to forty percent
forty something odd percent of uh all
coveted deaths were nursing home deaths
then they just stopped counting them you
can't find the updated new york's doing
the same thing now yeah
yeah and we couldn't get them in
michigan governor whitmer kind of
started and never finished
absolutely this is this is startling i
mean we talked about it with deep elm
this is really a post-apocalyptic
here's here's george floyd he's the king
and you know all
on the back of us of this sad guy who
was just totally drugged out
yeah and and it's so sad what's happened
to all these drug addicts
yeah but then they become this symbol
that the police
who basically are janitors for them now
they clean up their crap they take them
to the hospital and now when something
gets out of hand and there's a mistake
and something happens
the police get charged with murder right
yeah it is uh did you watch the full
body cam footage
it's very sad it was very sad and i
think what's going to happen
unfortunately is you're going to see
more backlash because
listen it's a tragedy we always said it
was an example of
improper police training but it there's
no example of malice or racism you know
they're really saying hey we're not
going to shoot you
get in the back of the car please we'll
roll down the window stay in the
background
i can't breathe sit in the car with me
i'm scared he was
and the officer i'll go officers i'll
roll down the window yeah yeah so
listen a tragedy still obviously but
there's no way they can make something
like second-degree murder stick
and when you talk with people here on
these streets and you say hey listen if
you watch the footage they go i don't
need to watch it to know that that
killing was murder
and it's it's it's really concerning
when it all becomes an excuse to riot
and burn things down
right to try to kill the us economy it's
what bill maher and all the democrats
said we want a depression we want a
recession we want a
crashing stock market so people reject
president trump
and so trump needs to get out there
trump needs to get out there and expose
the fact
that it is the democrats in the deep
state who are trying to crash the whole
economy to bring the entire us down
with them to have a new marshall plan
nationwide to bail them out because the
truth is the blue cities and blue states
have been horribly mismanaged their
kleptocracies they've robbed their
people
they're collapsing so now they're trying
to collapse the whole country to make
all the red states
and the midwest and other areas bail
them out so that's why they're trying to
bring the country down
and saying the dollar is going to die
and all the rest of this is because they
literally
know america is waking up to them so
they're trying to destroy us before we
actually wake up
oh look at that well see i don't know if
you know but this is what george floyd
would have wanted
well that's right i mean this atm people
not be able to get money out of it
it's representation of white supremacy
this is a symbol of white supremacy it's
like ilhan omar just said in southern
aoc
she said the banks and the businesses
and wall street it's all evil we're
going to destroy it and collapse it of
course then they'd be in somalia again
right which is what she doesn't seem to
understand that once you collapse the
civilization
yeah uh that then that doesn't empower
you that makes you poor
i was i was just joking i don't think
elon omar did that i think it's just
someone who committed a crime and used
it as an excuse
this is what's remarkable no i totally
agree what you're saying no no i
understand but they're in general saying
no borders no wall no usa at all let's
destroy it
the city of austin in the official
budget that's been put forward
says they want to blow up the police
station as a symbol of fighting
police misconduct so literally says this
the city of austin
in their official budget talks about
accelerating the controlled demolition
of the police department as a symbol of
getting rid of hate
and then making the police be broken up
and put in other uh
bureaucracies inside the city i swear to
god i know it sounds insane no no i i
understand what you're talking about
you're talking about defunding the
police some areas where they're talking
about abolishing the police
i don't know if this is the city council
kind of situation but what is
interesting is i know that listen you've
been anti sort of militarization of
police you've talked about that for a
long time
obviously you're more of a libertarian
where do you line up when you see this
and you see all the damage
we can keep walking um and you see do
you think that donald trump for example
in
in
portland or in seattle should be sending
in the feds the national guard
where do you line up on that people get
confused
about the fact that i'm against a police
state right
but i'm not against the police no the
democrats are the ones that want a
police state where you don't have due
process where you're surveilled where
you don't have free speech
where they can secretly arrest you they
don't want to get rid of the police
they want to take over the police
through the u.n run strong cities
initiative that obama and loretta lynch
hold on a second that's a hazard look at
that they didn't put that nail in right
the shoddy worksmanship you know i mean
if you're going to be a hobo
at least put in the nail right because
you could get some tetanus well
steven i'm glad you bring this up
because this is critical tetanus the
police
aren't the enemy now democrats want to
make the lowest level of government
the enemy because they know there's a
revolution against corrupt government
right they say let's have a revolution
let's burn down the local city hall
that's just so the democrats can take he
in full control so i'm not against
police
i'm against the democrats getting
control of the police and setting up a
police state
and back under clinton and i can ask you
one question i want you to see why why
do they give the
uh casino el camino a pass you know i
don't know why
that's that's that's a guy fieri go
there and have a buffalo burger
you know they they do have good burgers
there do they i've heard they've had
good burgers and we went in the other
day
i did have a burger not hurt they were
pretty good burgers but i've never seen
so many carabiner keychain clips
they all look the same that's how you
know they all look different in there
well i'll tell you this uh
one time our crew went in there and they
said we don't like ron paul we don't
like alex jones i probably had to eat
the burger here in 15 years
and uh my crew beat their bouncers asses
really yeah we
absolutely beat the [ __ ] out of well i
don't know if i would say that on camera
but go back to what you're talking about
the police state the police state oh
yeah here's one of the places that got
loaded right here you wanna go across
and look at it real quick sure don't let
us run
private stock or all saints tattoo
oh but i'm not really being coherent on
this police thing i'm trying to explain
it no no i understand back when
the federal government was more
globalist trying to turn the police
against us and saying
our main enemy is constitutional
terrorist and the police are going to
take our guns i'm against police
being captured by the deep state being
used against us but when the police wake
up to the new world order
like this happened and the globalists
and soros are unable to take control of
them
and soros of them try to then destroy
the police to take them over i totally
support the police in their
constitutional role
right yeah absolutely there is a
constitutional role for police namely to
protect citizens rights and when they
start violently looting and protesting
that's infringing on other people
absolutely the real out of control
system is the anarchy trying to set up
its own government they only want
anarchy for a few weeks
until they set up their government where
we have no rights just like in chop and
chaz
right people that weren't communists or
weren't you know basically devil
worshipers or antifa were not welcome
right that place was the ultimate police
state with a bunch of warlord goons
controlling it right i don't want our
police to turn into warlord goons
i don't want anarchists funded by george
soros who's overthrown ukraine and other
governments
setting it up again here well okay so
first off i want to go back to that what
happened here you said this place was
looted it seems like a lot of places
have had obviously windows smashed in
is there something particular that
happened here a lot of
places got robbed here in austin but
this one got caught on video
and you could time lapse it and actually
our crew was here wasn't savannah here
savannah was here she she caught some of
the best footage you can use it we'll
give it all to you thanks
and yeah everything we got is yours and
she caught well here's savannah come
over and tell
steven crowder about it okay so there
was a big blm right it was the george
floyd ryan's when
i first started yeah this is early on
yeah so they started up over there at
apd people started marching down
come closer so as mike picks it up and
start over oh okay i'm sorry about that
there's a lot of uh
rioting going on because of the george
uh riots at the beginning of
all of this it started up at apd they
marched down this way
and i ended up getting it perfectly on
film right when they went in they broke
down all these windows and again this is
a black owned business y'all
so they broke down the windows they
looted everything inside and they just
took off down the street there was
actually people in the bars because the
bars are still open
and i mean everyone the police were
standing there just watching as well
because there's nothing that they could
do there's just too much of it going on
now right now there's no one here so i
guess mike for some reason i always feel
like i'm in trouble when you walk up
with a camera right there you're about
to shout me down like stephen crowder is
funded by the
new world order that was a joke you know
no no i know but um
this is one of those situations where
okay we see this now is this is it
is this a style choice or this is bent
because they tried to re-loot it
i think they tried to reload it well
that's just silly because there's no
more private stock clearly
um my situation here is there's no one
around
so it was the writing and looting
because then you see footage for example
when we came in
there was nobody around then the next
morning we see footage of more riots and
looting and there's tear gas because of
garrett foster stuff going on
is it only happening at night because
it's completely dead yes it mainly
happens at night
okay and then now there's not very many
of the bars or restaurants open plus
they have limited numbers that can come
and i think it's like 25
everybody's wearing masks and then all
you have is basically roving gangs out
here
so like vampires that can't find anybody
to kill or feed off of
they then go down to the highway and the
frontage roads and the side roads and
they're now going off
up to i'd say 10 20 blocks away and now
looting people's cars
attacking people they're coming up to
old ladies cars yeah trying to drag them
out
i mean it's very frightening well it's
also exacerbated by the fact that i want
to get into kind of some local
laws so the mayor two thousand dollars
if you don't wear a fine or if you don't
wear a mask right
is that correct two thousand dollars per
person in your business not wearing a
mask
it's five hundred dollars last time i
checked per person not worrying about do
they find the business or do they find
their parents
they find the business 2000 and they
find the individual 500.
wow okay that was as a few weeks ago he
was threatening to raise it even more
but then he's been caught out and about
in an event's not wearing mask he lives
at the top of the w
but that's two city council members that
voted against me fighting the police
they all got violent visits at their
houses at night and he says he supports
it all
he says defund the police and it's in
the official budget that they are
proposing
to have a controlled demolition of the
police department as a symbol of
stopping
police abuse well i want to ask you
something because obviously you're
talking about uh we can keep walking so
people haven't seen the side of the
street
by the way i like what they're doing
there you have sacrament tattoo and all
saints tattoo i see a little irony a
little hipster irony
i'm really bad over here if you want to
cut over to the seventh that's that's
where the real
okay we can cut over to seven because
obviously you talk about sort of people
in power and organizations and it's
banned.video right bend that video
infowars.com but tim when should we cut
over to hit the all the homo stuff
maybe we should go that's where you want
this i'm not trying to direct you no i'm
fine we can go this way i don't care we
can also go up a few blocks cut over and
then go down it's all bad okay let's do
that
it's all bad it's not like there's any
lack
that i think is important for now that
is it there was too much looting for the
police to hang out there were these were
ordered to stand out they were ordered
to stand there
is that by the city council is that by
the mayor why don't you come here and
tell them
yeah yeah here jim tell them so i'm a
former apd officer
and for the last three except for this
last one this past saturday
that one was handled perfectly because
they had so much intelligence coming in
ahead of time
but when the george floyd riots first
happened
they honestly believed that the answer
was to show support
to the demonstrators that that would
help keep the violence down the police
were kneeling like
the police chief came out kneeled down
not anymore did everything
did everything they could and it didn't
matter they still broke in the stores
they still hit private stock
target all these different places and
now
they're just emboldened them in seattle
portland everything emboldened them
so now they got some great intelligence
in this over the last week before this
past saturday
that they were going to put men on top
of the rooms they finally brought into
you know enough officers to handle the
situation and more importantly
allow those officers to be proactive
right right and that made all the
difference
there wasn't a single business student
there was a single person hurt and tell
them what they were planning though that
finally made the state the city take
action
so what it finally took is they got
information in that
there was going to be demonstrators uh
that were going to be out there in gun
trucks
with uh armed individuals in the back of
these trucks yeah and those trucks
actually showed up last monday and
started doing dry runs right here on
sixth street walking around
really yeah blocking
and had a picture of them deploying up
in parking garages with
rifles as snipers well that's that's
getting to like detroit riots my
grandfather's in the air force he was
running reconnaissance
right because there were snipers on the
rooftops and uh i don't know if i would
say that this is surpassed the detroit
riots because it's such concentrated
violence
but it's definitely more at a national
level now let me say this this is one
thing where i think sometimes you and i
disagree i agree with what you're
talking about and obviously the funding
from black lives matter very well funded
antifa the people who showed up
yesterday but i still think that a lot
of these looters and a lot of this
damage is not
paid for and organized they're just yeah
i agree with you
but but soros and these groups and the
media saying it's legitimate to loot and
attack people
they trigger it and then once it starts
that's how it runs wild
in fact three years ago we got secret
george soros documents that they
confirmed were theirs
where alexander soros was running this
main group that funds antifa
and it talks about their mission is to
go out and to get locals to loot and
burn things
right that they trigger so so they're
just the detonators well i don't even
think you want to go maybe shoot
something real quick in front of willie
or just
now let's just keep going point out
anything that's going on that there's a
specific story because it's your you're
showing me around your hometown there
are just homeless shelters basically on
every corner here yeah
and then they change the rule now where
they're allowed to approach you
physically to panhandle so we want to
look forward to
also sleep in front of your house okay
and again this just encourages people to
take drugs
and get their welfare check and then
just camp out over by my office now
routinely they just grill under the
overpass and they're just camping out
how do they afford a grill uh because
they get all this welfare money and they
panhandle
gosh well that's a sweet gig if you can
at least listen you're homeless but you
have a weber under an overpass that's uh
i'm thinking about moving into there
y'all just take some heroin lay back
drink some
drink some beer actually she didn't she
just appeared on camera angela who works
was wonderful she saw some people
shooting up heroin the other day
um just right here in austin i i guess
too my question is um
well here's what happens this is what
really destroys me just like you seen
the black lives matter riots
and i don't necessarily think the secret
stuff with soros is as important as the
actual charter
publicly from black lives matter when
you start a movement that's complete
abolition of the police and prisons in
the nuclear family
to me that's enough because that's a set
point and of course everyone's going to
act unlawfully but what happens here in
austin with the homeless folks
and i grew up in montreal at one point
we had more homeless people per capita i
think than anywhere in north america or
at least it was close
um the first person came up i bought him
a coffee the second person i know was
the yellow taco place taco delight and
then when it's four five
six in a ten minute period you become
desensitized it dehumanizes people it
doesn't actually help them it
dehumanizes them because they become
background noise
absolutely it's just like if you feed
animals in your backyard they stop
hunting themselves
right and that's what's happening here
and of course we're not comparing
homeless people to animals but we're
talking about the idea
yeah it just becomes white noise where
you go well usually you might say hey
man i don't have any you want to see the
police department they want to blow up
it's right there
okay we're almost there they're still
trying to blow it up
it is in the official proposal
brought forward by the city council and
and
and the majority that wants to get rid
of the police or defund them
to blow up the in fact here's tim tim
come over here
i swallowed a bug so he should be apd i
know crowders having trouble believing
it
am i joking that they officially want to
blow this up no so uh jimmy flagging of
the austin city council
uh sent a memo out to all his fellow
council members and in that
memo that we have a copy of he literally
says that we need to call for the
expedited demolition
of apd headquarters uh the removal of a
lot of the
commanders and assistant chiefs at apd
because they're not playing ball with
the city council
and so they want to replace them with
civilians hand-picked by the city
council
to oversee such important functions as
apd patrol
apd detectives bureau basically all the
important divisions with apd they want
to take police leadership out of those
positions
and replace them with hand-picked city
council and mayor well no it's not that
i didn't believe you it's this is this
was going to be my question and you just
answered it uh tim
was it just answered i was wondering if
you know they're demolishing it because
they're going to move it to a nicer
facility like now we're moving to a
penthouse suite no no they actually want
to blow it up so they don't have a
building
right and they said that they feel like
by
getting rid of some of the commanders
some of the assistant chiefs and then
whatever leadership
is left over that they can't legally get
rid of because some of those positions
require
a sworn law enforcement officer to be in
those understanding law
so what they're going to do is spread
them out to
other city buildings already existing
okay so let me explain what's going on
i don't just say soros because he's a
buggy man
he literally has given over a billion
dollars to anti-fun black lives matter
in the last six years it's on record he
brags about it but it gets worse
he's financed over 500 what's the best
way to cross if we want to see them well
i guess we can just show it from across
the way
stephen if you put any of your peaches
put this in there no this is all going
in no that's going to get it right right
soros has gotten hundreds of da's and
hundreds of mayors
and all these state attorney generals
like leticia james
and like the crazy lady in st louis who
literally arrested indict people who
defend their houses
and so they now have gotten the george
soros guy as the new
uh city attorney who openly says defund
the police and who's a public communist
right
so they're putting communists in charge
right they're almost in control and now
they say they're going to blow up the
police station
that's that people are like well alex
you're just a police state i'm against
a police state we're about to have the
communist in full control of the police
and to bring them under heel they're
saying we're going to blow up your damn
building and one thing i wanted to point
out here just because
listen i'm not a supporter of the green
new deal obviously right i'm not a
neo-environmentalist but the left
wrecks everything but i also don't
believe in littering i get i don't know
about you i get pissed my someone throws
something out there five years ago this
was all beautiful it was beautiful my
brother went to ut i was gonna say this
is probably
the dirtiest city if you guys can see
the river it looks like a hobbit would
walk out from under it but now you go
down here
there's needles and feces and hepatitis
everywhere look at this why don't
why don't they have an organization in
the city here if they're talking about
community organizing to just clean stuff
they get 30 something times the money
they got 50 years ago for the homeless
here or more
and none of it goes to them the
democrats siphon it all off and they
steal every damn bit of it
yeah this is filthy this is not what it
was when you smell that fish
yeah i do i smell that bum piss you know
what that bump is really is that's the
smell of the dander
of dust mites i don't know
i thought it was i thought it was just
bump this is bad enough i think
i think bub piss is worse than dust
mites i'm allergic to bump fish i'm
serious
oh you need some water oh oh my god i'm
serious i smell that [ __ ] i can't do it
uh no i have some but let's uh i guess
we can stop right here in front of the
jesus christ no i wasn't putting an
actor that smell man you smell that
jesus
yeah it smells like pee you guys want it
let's cross here i think this is not
what it is it's
only people in the city who obey actual
crosswalks okay so let's
well the hand says stop but who really
cares at this point hey you usually just
take the highway over now if you want to
you know
no i don't want to get on the freeway i
don't either that's the job i want to
get on a bird scooter
on that loop hey is it true the guy who
created that one loop to alleviate
traffic the uh
the civil engineer the architect killed
himself i didn't know that i don't know
if it's true or not
um let me ask you this because we are
going to wrap this up here
it's really sad to see what's happened
to austin i don't recognize the city
again my brother went to ut for four
years
he was at ut when you know you guys won
the uh won the big bowl there with vince
young who scored lower than statistical
random on the
qb test um here it is good shots right
here keep going
what do you what do you want to see done
what i want to see done
what needs to be done right now what's
the biggest problem facing cities like
austin
we have to recognize that there is a
multinational
united nations corporate operations at
the who and through unesco
called menualization where they come in
at the city level and get them to pass
carbon taxes
and green new deals that shut down all
the businesses not owned
by inside groups and who consolidate the
wealth and power
then they come in and they put in their
county attorneys their city attorneys
and then they start prosecuting the
general public while releasing the
criminals
and they destabilize the cities and
implode them
and then buy up the infrastructure for
pennies on the dollar so what this is
is an infrastructure takeover of all the
major cities the united states then they
tell the third world
hey everything's free come in we'll
we'll be a sanctuary city but
they administer all of this replacement
migration being brought up but what can
people watching right now
or people watching what can they do
because a lot of people feel helpless
right now listen you're in a city
your business gets looted you're shut
down you can't run a business
right now your employees are collecting
a check business owners aren't collected
what can they do we're being made to be
dependent don't follow the mask rules
don't take their
welfare in these cities stop following
their regulations and rules
because they're not americans they're
globalists that are using your
compliance
to get rid of the country we have outlaw
criminal government
run by the globalist imploding our
cities by design and you must recognize
that they're the enemy
you must recognize that this is 21st
century warfare and you must decry them
and then say don't support any leftist
or globalist stores whether they're
small
or big and people should hang a shingle
out on their businesses letting people
know
that they're populist they're free
market and they're pro america
and that you're not going to follow
their garbage just like that new jersey
just like that new jersey gym that has
been reopening regardless what happens
those guys are folk heroes
when the government becomes criminal in
these blue cities we have to become
robin hood and stop following the
regulations
and we have to resist them at every turn
what about because i will say this i
think that the mask thing is
is kind of silly because of the way
people are using masks when the cdc was
saying don't use mask i said well
actually if you're sick
a mask is a good idea long time ago yeah
i have a problem the way it's being
implemented
i disagree and that people out there i
would say it's not worth the fine don't
disobey the law but you can still open
your businesses while not following the
rules
i mean holland in holland and sweden
their top scientists said that the maps
don't help you
right also i'm not saying don't help me
i just don't want people going out there
breaking the law they're getting fined
no i hear you but at a certain point i
would say wear a mask if you don't want
to get fined and then you know go to the
gym
sure exactly but they told rosa parks so
at the back of the bus it was the law
yeah and at a certain point we got to
have civil disobedience right and so all
i'm saying is
they're having mass compliance to
prepare us for forced inoculations
they gates has funded at mit and rice
university
a digital tattoo that goes under the
skin to prove that you've been
inoculated
they are establishing world government
and wearing the mask like a hajib or
a burqa in islam is a sign
of submission to the globalist and falci
has said
it's a sign of your submission to them
and the medical cartel
that's been wrong about everything they
said 2.2 million people would die it's
150 000. they count people that die from
gunshot wounds and car wrecks in the
kova column they count the flu
so yes there's a real virus and it's not
as bad as the regular pneumonia
and we're being taught this fear and
this hysteria and that's the cover
to make the good people be locked down
in their houses then the democrats
activate all their organizations to come
out and take over the country
that's what this pencer attack is you
know what i see in austin too is um
i think people don't understand
necessarily like you said the unintended
consequences or intended consequences
for some
of these coveted regulations what you
have is you have a street where
businesses are shut down
you have streets that are desolate
there's no one around it's like detroit
you know that's detroit my hometown
where
the reason there's so much crime is
there's no one there to witness it
you're in a downtown area
and it's almost rural and you're seeing
that here one night we were out we
didn't see
anyone for i think it was six minutes we
didn't see a single person
who show up or wearing masks so you have
no people no witnesses no real police
support
no businesses and complete anonymity
it's got to
increase crime well that's right it's
totally apocalyptic
and i've been to detroit several times i
was there in the 80s and it was okay but
a little scary i was there about four
years ago for a wedding
and it literally looked like something
out of a science fiction dystopia
after civilization is collapsed you add
mass to that and you're right
a lot of austin now in the downtown
areas looks
like detroit looks and it's very sad but
but here's something that's really
and it didn't that's pretty fast that it
happened yeah i mean detroit took
decades this just took a few months
right
so this is an accelerated planned
collapse but here's what i started this
off with and
i'd like to end with this last time you
remember when i was making platform two
and a half years ago
yeah and i told the world you're next
because i was reading the different
corporate plans
now hundreds and hundreds of doctors
nurses epidemiologists
virologists scientists some of the heads
of major hospitals
come out and say things like there's
hundreds of studies that
hydroxychloroquine has like a 99
rate with somebody who gets on it and
then fauci puts out a bill gates study
that's been withdrawn
from being fraudulent but even nbc
reports that and
he's okay they use that fake study for
the u.n to say
we say hydroxychloroquine is not
approved even though it is approved for
use
and now even pharmacies won't give it
out too many doctors
because fauci says and the u.n says even
though they have the medical degrees
bill gates who's running all this does
not have that medical degree and since
when
are hundreds of doctors unable to have
press conferences
in america and they take it off youtube
they take it off google they take it off
twitter they take it off facebook and
now they're talking about
trying to take breitbart servers away
because they're hosting the video of
this that's why we have banned
dot video that's what band videos
exploded because all these people that
have been banned
were able to come there that's what
we're having videos routinely with a
million two million views yeah because
and so that's the future but now we have
the democrats in deep state
and other organizations openly harassing
our server companies
and telling them you can't carry this
this is dangerous so they say build your
own thing
but then they go after every piece of
your infrastructure which is beyond
censorship
this is authoritarian takeover of the
mind where now even doctors with medical
degrees that are respected
aren't allowed to speak because fauci
and the undead and bill gates say no
i'll give you one more we say everyone
says trust the experts right you're
a science environment well i don't think
fauci has actually practiced medicine
with patients
in 30 years 40 years i don't have exact
numbers i've been there 45 years
yeah and folks out there did the
research on dr fauci and the aids
epidemic and the kind of stuff he was
spouting back then
yeah and i'm not saying that he doesn't
know what he's talking about in certain
areas but i certainly have a problem
with doctors who are practicing and
actually
serving their patients right doctors
who've taken the hippocratic oath who
are trying to actually
you're right and they're not considered
experts
the patent on two of the vaccines
he owns part of the patent on two of
them how is that on a conflict of
interest and it goes further
further they've skipped animal trials
never before done
and they're having an 80 rate of people
getting sick in these studies even cbs
news
they've never had these because it's not
a regular vaccine where they put an
attenuated piece of the virus into you
and your body learns to have immunity
against it
there's still some side effects but it's
a real technology this is dna vaccines
that go into the nuclei
and reprogram your cell to create a
protein
so so now you're going to be like a gmo
creature if you take these vaccines look
it up
okay i haven't looked it up but uh it
sounds pretty scary it's absolutely
frightening and so
i mean well it does scare me though that
i can observe with my own eyes and we do
know statistically like we said it'll be
interesting to people out there hey
listen if you guys can find these
numbers
for us what percentage of covet deaths
are nursing home related they stopped
keeping record i haven't seen them from
michigan
forty percent it was it was about 40 but
they stopped a long time ago 47
yeah yeah and now but you can't find
those upgrades now they will not release
the numbers
they won't release crime numbers either
they won't release crime numbers uh on
interracial crime statistics right now
on rape statistics a lot of these
numbers keep changing that's why we had
some
bureau of justice or was it department
of justice or fbi i think we'll have the
overlay here
uh about who was committing which crimes
you know number one uh cause of death
for young black americans homicide
we say that because we want to actually
help all black lives not the very very
small percentage of that's right
we have the fbi statistics we put them
out on instagram and instagram bandum
where it shows ten to one black on white
crime yeah
but they've stopped recording them that
way i think were those 2008 statistics
or 2012
because they've changed the way they do
statistics and we can't find some and
that's what's really concerning to me if
we're going to talk about
listen silencing information we should
all be on board with at least providing
information to the people the truth is
the democrat cities is where everybody's
getting killed no matter what color they
are right and the big
the most dangerous place for a black
person's in their mother's womb and
thank god margaret sanger's main
original planned parenthood
in new york took her name off of it
because she actually said black people
need to be exterminated as weeds
so how is her name on the planned
parenthood buildings
so the left's finally figuring out hey
this is somebody that said kill all the
black people
and but but she's supposedly a liberal
right i mean margaret sanger
hitler gave her awards and said what i
know i know from you
right so so margaret sanger inspired
hitler yeah
i mean we talk about henry ford being
anti-semitic which we know he had kind
of wrote some letters through the nazis
but still wasn't actually exterminating
black people in record numbers as the
plan we saw carried out by margaret
sanger
if you're going to take down memorials
for jefferson or abraham lincoln for
god's sake
you got to take that name off the uh the
marquis well her name would be first i
mean this is the woman that said
oh of course we need to exterminate the
black race yes she said okay so so this
is the woman the left
puts on the cover of time magazine and
newsweek it shows what's
cold springs harbor run by all these
liberals up in new york that's the main
eugenics base right that's what bill
gates is into that's what his dad was
into
his dad ran planned parenthood looking
at cold springs harbor yeah well i think
you just even look into planned
parenthood as a whole it's bad enough
it's getting pretty hot alex let's tell
him one last time when i find you i
really appreciate you making the time i
want to say this is awesome brother it's
good
thank you i'm glad we've always had you
on and you know if you see me
you've not been a coward like almost
everybody else has been a coward you've
had me on back when they were actually
restricting people that did have me on
now and we kind of broke through the
blockade so people don't get in trouble
to interview us but
uh do they not we get in trouble no
matter what we do so it's kind of white
noise again
yeah well we got in trouble for the chat
stream they took that down on facebook
because they said we were inciting
violence
where we went to chaz we actually rented
out raz simone we rented out airbnb
you're not supposed to show what's
happening
yeah they declared that so you know
they're having an alex jones video been
ain't gonna mean all that much to me
just remember folks all those doctor
videos and if he ever gets banned god
forbid
they're all at band dot video and
newswards infowars.com and this guy's
awesome
support him and be part of the mug club
get out of these awesome t-shirts right
here
because this is one of the few guys out
there that's not a coward look let's get
him some water and get him away from the
what is it hobo pissed dandruff what's
it called
well i mean i have dusty mites yes they
live in hobo piss
yeah we'll talk about this after the ems
and i've talked to medical doctors and
what makes you nauseated it's not just
the smell of the piss
what we call the smell of bum piss that
has that sweet nauseating smell
yeah i wouldn't say sweets well it does
have a sweet and it's a sweet stench
makes me want to throw up like rotten
meat
it is it is the crap of dust mites
and that smell just man they wanted to
torture me i shouldn't be able to they
would lock me up yeah that's not good
yeah they could waterboard you with hobo
piss is it exclusive to bum
piss as opposed by the way where are all
these loving liberals
we saw women out there on the ground
with sores all over their bodies like
day of the dead zombies
and we have shanty towns we drive hell
there's a giant shanny town only 100
yards why do you want to see that
in with that i don't want to go to the
shaney town well let's just know we
ended on bumpers you and i was talking
now
you're not going to beat dust might bump
us alex
texas
usa look at that swap go into it
subject for today
the thoughts the thoughts it cannot be
the emotions the feelings that you
experience
so what is the nature of i
what does that word mean or point to
untouched by time
every answer generates further questions
you